in response to the home invasion attack
on Nancy Pelosi's husband Paul Pelosi
Elon Musk fresh off of buying Twitter
tweeted a Bonkers conspiracy theory from
the Santa Monica Observer a paper a
publication which previously reported
that Hillary Clinton died before the
2016 election and a body double was
debating Donald Trump
uh Elon Musk tweeted such a conspiracy
theory that claims or suggests that the
home Invader was actually Paul Pelosi's
gay lover
completely baseless and ultimately
deleted that this is the owner of
Twitter that did this article about this
on CBS News Elon Musk tweets and deletes
link to article pushing unfounded
conspiracy theory about Paul Pelosi
attack and it reads Elon Musk Sunday
tweeted and deleted a link to an article
pushing an unfounded conspiracy theory
about the attack on Paul Pelosi the
tweet from musk who now owns Twitter
raised concerns about the type of
content that will be allowed on social
media on the social media site under his
control yeah that's an understatement in
a sense deleted tweet responding to
Hillary Clinton musk wrote there is a
tiny possibility there might be more to
this story than meets the eye with a
link to a story from the right wing
website Santa Monica Observer a site
that has pushed anti-lgbt conspiracy
theory regarding the attack according to
an archived version of the story The
Outlet previously made false claims
including that Hillary Clinton died on 9
11 and was replaced by a look-alike you
can still find an archive of the story
that was posted and
um the story says it doesn't add up
people on social media are questioning
the attack on Paul Pelosi and it says
you know San Francisco's gay bars close
at 2 A.M and what happened was the bars
closed Paul Pelosi went home with his
lover and it was a lover's quarrel a
lover's quarrel now Ben Collins on MSNBC
explains how this entire thing got going
and it really is instructive in terms of
how this nonsense starts with a spark
and very quickly becomes a fire that is
difficult to put out first of all lies
on the earth move faster than the truth
and that's in part why there are all
these safeguards that Elon Musk is
trying to take down on Twitter right now
the lies that were pushed were from Bad
pieces of information they found for
example they said that Paul Pelosi was
uh in his underwear of course he was 2
30 in the morning at the time he was
attacked that led them to believe this
was a lover's quarrel between two
different people that knew each other
the reason they believed they knew each
other is because the police put out a
statement saying that they didn't really
know who opened the door so they that
led them to believe there was a third
person in the house
so from there there was this World
building on the pro-trump internet what
could be the opposite of reality here
in the opposite reality they came up
with was these two people were having a
lover's quarrel in a house and the
police sort of intruded on us
it's fundamentally incorrect it was
pushed by the richest man in the world
and then yesterday it was pushed by
Donald Trump Jr who posted a picture of
underwear and a hammer and said it's a
Halloween costume for Papa Lucy
if we don't cut this out right now not
just the normalization of violence but
the idea that reality can't even exist
anymore because it cannot catch up to
the lies on the internet
I'm not a scholar on authoritarian
history but I've let I've read Hannah
Ren I've read all these people
this is how it gets really bad
this is the start of something that gets
really really bad yeah and Ben Collins
is of course completely correct and the
added layer to it now is forget about
whether Elon Musk is going to properly
moderate at Twitter the dissemination of
outrageous disinformation he's
participating in spreading it which is a
new dystopian layer altogether let me
know what you think find me on Twitter
and remember if you are watching our
content on YouTube and you are not
subscribed
what on Earth are you thinking no in all
seriousness our YouTube channel is on
its way to 2 million subscribers we
found out
that there are millions of YouTube
viewers who watch our content every
month and don't subscribe make sure to
hit that subscribe button it does so
much for us it is the most important
indicator to YouTube Hey should we
recommend David Pacman's content or Not
So speaking specifically to those of you
who watch the clips but that subscribe
button is enabled because you're not
currently subscribed do us a favor and
hit that button we'll be at 2 million
subscribers before you know it we will
take a quick break and be back right
after this
when you're busy during the day and you
need a quick snack sometimes you're just
in the mood for something sweet that's
when I reach for monk pack our sponsor
monk pack offers gooey granola bars that
melt in your mouth as well as nut and
Seed bars that are perfectly crunchy
sweet and salty but the best part is
that each bar is plant-based with only
one gram of sugar two to three net carbs
and only about 150 calories it's great
if you're doing keto or low carb or like
me you just want to minimize your sugar
intake I can't get enough of dark
chocolate cocoa I'm just a chocolate guy
it's great but they come in other
flavors too like sea salt dark chocolate
caramel sea salt they just launched
peanut butter cocoa chip and dark
chocolate cocoa if you don't love monk
pack as much as our entire team does
monk pack will give you your money back
go try monk pack keto granola bars and
nut and Seed bars go to monkpack.com and
use the code Pacman for twenty percent
off the link is down below